started so hello and thank you for
joining us
uh welcome to the first richard m carp
distinguished lecture
this semester my name is peter bartlett
i'm the associate director of the
science institute for the theory of
computing
we established this rm carp series to
celebrate the
pioneering role in theoretical computer
science of
simon's institute founding director dick
carr and we're grateful to the many
contributors to the richard encart fund
for their support of the series
the series features visionary leaders in
the field of theoretical computer
science on topics associated with
current programs that are running at the
institute
and it's geared towards a broad
scientific audience so this semester the
summers institute's hosting two
entirely online programs not quite
entirely there's a small
in-person component ones on the
theoretical foundations of computer
systems and ones on satisfiability
theory practice and beyond
and i'm delighted to welcome our speaker
today owner grumberg who's a participant
in the program on theoretical
foundations of computer systems
orner is a professor in computer science
at the technion
she's a member of academia european an
acm fellow
she holds a phd in computer science at
technion an honorary doctorate from the
technical university of munich
her research interests include automated
verification of software and hardware
automated program repair exploiting
model checking to find security
vulnerabilities
refinement and modularity and model
checking temporal logics and automata
on infinite objects she's a co-author of
model checking
a main reference book in the field of
formal verification who work on
counter-example guided abstraction
refinement has won the
award from the international conference
on computer aided verification
and today we're delighted to have her
presenting a talk entitled
automated program repair using formal
verification techniques
welcome warner hello thank you for the
introduction peter
so um i will be talking about automated
program repair using
formal verification technique uh
this is based on just a moment it's not
moving
this is based on
on joint work with
haddad frankel rottenberg
chain vault it consists of
two different works that i will describe
separately so in general one of the
building block that we count on is model
checking
which is the tool for a verification
and model checking
receives a system a model of the system
and specification and it checks whether
the system satisfies the specification
and it answers both yes if the system
does satisfy the specification
and no plus counter example
otherwise and the counter example is
very useful
especially when our goal is to repair
a program in
we will focus on formal automated
program
repair where model checking will find a
bug in the program
and bug will be a program run that
violates the specification
and the repair tool will automatically
suggest
repairs one or more
where a repair is a change to the
program called
a code that results in a correct program
automated program repair
it's a very active research area
and most of the works are actually taste
test based and not formal verification
based
in test based we are given a
set of buggy tests and a set of
correct tests and we suggest a repair
that will
correct the body test and will preserve
the correctness of the correct one
in contrast in formal verification
technique we have a
program and a specification and we
suggest a repair
so that the repaired problems satisfy
the specification
so the first work that i'm going to
describe
focuses on the notion of must fault
localization which goes hand-in-hand
with program repair assume that
in general in program repair we are
given a buggy program
we are taking the program
through some some
procedure repair procedure and will
result
in a patched program that is correct
where the patch
as said is some changes to the program
to the program code so
for false localization assumed that we
are given
a buggy program with a violating run
for localization will identify locations
in the run that might be
relevant for the bag and now we can
we can choose one or more of this
location and change them and as a result
may find a correct program
so fault localization is
actually the goal of localization is to
focus the programmers attention on
locations that might
be relevant to the bug and it's
important to
have good false localization because
if a fortrocalization is too restrictive
then we might miss a potential repair
and if it is too permissive then it may
cause
extra search work
often for localizations our type
of may for localization where there is
no guarantee that
all returned locations are relevant know
that every relevant location is returned
we are going to suggest a novel notion
of must fault localization
it turns out that when defining mass
fault localization we need to consider
the repair scheme
where the repair scheme actually
identifies the changes that are allowed
to program changes a statement
while doing the repair for instance
the program scheme that we will
relate to in this talk will be
a program scheme called s mute for
mutation
and it allows syntactic replacement of
operators
in the right hand side of assignment and
conditions
so for example we may replace a plus by
minus or a greater than a with a
a smaller than or a constant
with a constant plus one
the must false localization then is a
set of locations that contains at least
one location from each from any
successful repair to the bag
this means that it is impossible to fix
the bug
using only locations outside of this set
or in other words any repair for the
this specific bag must use at least
one location from this set
must must notion uh as
a as i mentioned before mass notion
depends on the
chosen repair scheme and
we we match
our a must for localization to s mute
actually it also preserve the
sr but i will not get into this
so our setting since we are doing formal
automated program repair we have a
specification
and the program is supposed to
satisfy the specification for all input
however we will restrict ourselves to
a verification which is bounded this is
very common for
in a program verification
we're bounded means that we just
guarantee that
every run of the program up to a certain
bound
will not violate the assertion
the program repair that we use
is search-based we just
have the search space of all possible
patch programs
and we generate in
a one program at a time and we validate
whether it's
correct or not the validation usually is
done
by means of smt or sat solvers
so we just generate one program
and if it's true if it correct then
it is going to the user
and otherwise it is it is just thrown
away
i will explain the algorithm for must
false localization by example
so let's have a simple program
you don't have to try to understand what
this program does because it does
nothing interesting
but it has a bug and the bug
having a bug means that it just violate
one of the assertion in the code
so let's see an example of a bug we
start with an
input of in which
x is zero and w is zero and now
t becomes zero and y becomes
minus three z becomes plus 3
and when we get to the condition
we see that w is not greater than 3
because
w is 0. so the if
is not taken and
rather the assertion is reached
and now we check the assertion y is
minus 3
and z is 3 which
violate the assertion which requires
that y will be greater than z
so this is a violating run of the
program
and the first thing that we do is to
transform the program
into a set of constraints so
this is done the set of constraints is
in the form of
static single single static assignment
ssa and the way it is done is just
to attach with every occurrence
of the variable a new indexed variable
so for instance here we assign a y
with the value x minus so here
this assignment a transform into a
constraint that
state that y 0 equals x
0 minus 3. the next time we assign to y
and
sorry the next time y is the sign
y get the value of y plus 10
then we have y one this is the second
occurrence of y
which is equal to y 0 plus 10
and to the set of constraints or we have
another point
the conditions in the if are assigned to
a boolean variables
and now if we want to know at this point
which value y received
we have a white tree this is another
occurrence of y
which is if g0 holds
then we take the value of y
a1 and otherwise y0 which means actually
that we
check the condition of
the if and if this condition holds then
we take
the value of y1 and otherwise we take
the value
of y0 and now we add
to this set of constraints the negation
of the assertions if we have several
assertions this is the negation of their
conjunction or negation of each one
and this young disjunct them all
this means that if we find a satisfying
assignment
to this set of constraints then this
actually
represents a behavior of the program
that
violates the assertion meaning a buggy
behavior so here we have
a buggy behavior represented by
by means of the indexed variables
and now we want to compute the set of
locations that are
responsible for this bug so the first
thing that we do
is to have a dependency graph
a static dependency graph that
has the indexed variables
as nodes and we have an edge between
y 2 and y 0 if
y 0 y 2 depends on y 0
and we see that y 2 depends on y 0
if g 0 is false
this comes from this from here y
2 gets the value of y 0 when
g 0 is false other it also depends on
why a 1 n depends on g 0
and so on and now when we
uh want to a to compute
default localization we are interested
in specific bug
so in that case we have another
another graph in which we only
take the dependencies that correspond to
the specific assignment that we have so
in in particular this assignment
um satisfies node g
0 and therefore we only choose
y z y 0 and g 0
as influencing y 2.
once we have this dynamic dependency
graph
then we can cons we can compute
the slice for y2
and the slice for the z0
the the reason that we take the slice
for these two
is that the this assertion is violated
and um this assertion uses
the y2 nz z0
these are the the constraints
that influence the value of y2 and zero
according to the dynamic graph
and finally the mast fault localization
set
is the actually statement from the
program
that correspond to this one so this is
the mass
force localization set that we obtained
when we implemented the mast fault
localization we implemented
it within a repair tool called a
all repair which is based on generate
and validate and returns all minimal
repairs
from the search space based on s
mute and the minimalities with respect
to the number of changes
a number of mutations applied to the
code
so let's look again at this picture
what happens here is that once we
generate
a patch program we check it and if it's
correct then not only we eliminate from
the search space
this particular program but we also
eliminate other programs in which
the patch is larger is a superset
of the the actual
patch that was used here in this way we
just
prune some of the search space with
which helps um in making the
algorithm uh more efficient because the
heavy part is going over the surf space
one by one
and checking each one whether it's
it is validate or not
so now we want to improve it and
so we already have some pruning when
a correct mutated program is generated
but we also want to have pruning of the
cell
space when the buggy a buggy mutated
program is generated
and here what we will do we will
eliminate
similar buggy mutated program
and here we are going to use default
localization idea
so when we are when we are having an
unsuccessful repair then we
obtain a mutated program which is
buggy and now we want to eliminate
all the all other programs
that have the same set of
er
sorry we identified the master
location set for this program and we
just
eliminate all the a program
that have the same statement as
this pm so if
another program share
is shared the same set
of matched location set then
it will contain exactly the same bug and
therefore we can
uh pawn it from the search space
without even checking it and this saves
a lot of
efforts so what we do right now
we take again we generate a program
and if it is incorrect then not only
we prune it from the search space but
also
all others that share the same
fault localization set and as before
if it's correct then we prune all
programs that are a superset
of changes uh
we have a theorem that says that
actually
when we add false localization to all
repel we
result in a sound a complete algorithm
which means that
no good repair is eliminated by our
opponent
of the search space
we had we compared
all repair with and without fault
localization
and what is interesting is the
instances which took
the most amount of time and here
each dot here is a different instance
the red
represents the time it took with the
photocallisation and the blue
without and we see that
with the full localization we have a
great improvement a great speed up
we even have some cases where
the all repair was timed out well
for er for localization all repair
returned result so just to summarize we
suggested
a novel notion of must fault
localization
with respect which depends on the
specific repair scheme
that we use it's must not may meaning
that
we must change at least one of the
suggested
statement and uh
we showed that this
notion um obtain with this notion we
obtained
a significant pruning of the self-space
for all repair
without losing any good potential repair
so now i want to move to another
notion of repair which is quite
different
it uses a assume guarantee
which is verification scheme
a widely used verification scheme
and if this scheme
fails to verify the problem and found
the counter example
then we suggest a repeal
the goal here is to exploit the
partition of the system
into component and use compositional
model checking
to verify small components and to
conclude the correctness
of the full system and if a bug is found
to repair it to apply repair to one of
the components
so our setting now is c
like communicating systems and
a safety specification given as an
automaton
so here is a program the program is
quite simple
it reads a password
from some input
channel and as long as the password is
too short
it has has less than three digits
then it reads another password and so on
until it obtained a password which is
long enough
once it does it it send it for
encryption
um the
the password the result the encrypted
password
is assigned to past2
so this is the way we describe this
program
and this is actually the control flow
graph of the program
and the reason we choose to describe it
this way
is that this is very similar to
automaton
and we want to use automata learning
algorithms
so here you see that
we read some
input this is the question mark we read
the value
of x from the input we check whether
it's
smaller smaller than 999
and read again and so on um
when the password is long enough
we send it to encryption
descending is with exclamation mark
and then we wait for the other component
to send us an encrypted password
via the channel get
encrypted
when we have several components in the
system
they synchronize on the common
on the common channel so here we see
that
they share shall encrypt and
get encrypt the two components shared
these channels
but the channel in is actually
a channel that comes from the
environment of this
component it's just an input and
therefore there is no synchronization
here
so the first component and actually it's
n2 later on
it just reads the password then it
checks
whether it's long enough as much as
needed
and when it's long enough then it's
synchronized with the other
component and it sends it
its value the other component
then uh encrypt the value where the
encryption
is just multiplied by two is not very
deep encryption
but uh it's simple and
then it sends it back to the
first component through the channel
getting crit
the kind of the of specification we are
going to use
is again described as an automaton
here the alphabet is the communications
so we may describe that we always want
first to read at least one occurrence
of the of a password from the input
and only then synchronize
on the encoding
so this is syntactic requirement that
actually describe what
sequences of communications are allowed
in addition we also have syntactic
semantic requirements which are
expressed using constraints over local
variables of the two components so for
instance
we may require that
the and the entered password is
different from the encrypted password
this is uh described by requiring that
x1 this is the input at the beginning
is different from x2 which is the
value obtained from the encrypt
encryption another
requirement which is semantic
might be that there is no overflow
so here we require
that x2 after encryption is smaller than
2 to the 64.
since we are going to apply verification
we will need
also an error state and the arrow state
is is such that transitions are sent to
it
when the the constraints are not
satisfied so for instance here we
require that the password will be
different than the encrypted password
and if they are equal they go to error
and the same here if we require that
the encryption is
smaller than 2 to the 64 then if it's
greater or equal to
2 to the 64 then we send
the behavior to to the arrow state
so now we want to exploit the assumed
guarantee framework
which is commonly used for a
compositional verification
so what we have here we have we have two
components
m1 and m2 and we want to verify that
this satisfies
they satisfy p so the first thing we do
we take a one and we
check it in together with a which is
some
sun assumption on the
behavior of the environment of m1
so we check whether m1 composed with
this assumption on the environment
satisfies p next we check
whether this assumption uh faithfully
describe
m2 this is the other part
and if both premises hold then we can
conclude that
m1 composed with m2 satisfies p
so this is the way assume guarantee
is usually done it has a component
of learning and the learning
just learned the assumption
on the environment we then check here
the premises of the loop of the
rule and if the premises hold then we
can
return a positive result
we can say that indeed p holds in n1
composed with m2
if um in this case
well mai composed with
m1 does not satisfy p then
the conclusion is that we need to
strengthen
ai to eliminate some behaviors from a
i and here we need to weaken the
assumptions
on the other hand if we find the counter
example
and we see that it's real then we can
conclude
that m1 composed with m2 is indeed
violated
and what we did in addition to
adapting this framework to our setting
is to add a component of repair
so if we get a violation of
p in m1 composed with m2 then
we repair m2 and we check again whether
m1 composed with the repaired m2
satisfied the the required property
so let's see how we do it for our
setting
elstar in general is an algorithm for
learning
in unknown language l by iterative
interaction between
a learner and a teacher which is an
oracle that we have to implement and
actually
say how it should answer the the
specific questions from the learner
and the learner has two kind of
questions
it asks membership queries which is
a is a certain word in the language
the unknown language l and at some point
the learner has some conjecture
of how an automaton for this language
l should look like and then it asks an
equivalent
queries which is whether this
the language of the
the conjecture a equals l
um l-star is guaranteed to
terminate and work well when
the unknown language is regular
it's regular language and it is over
a finite alphabet unfortunately in our
setting we have
infinite state problems with first order
constraints which is not necessarily
regular if we are not careful
so the first thing that we need to do is
to
make the alphabet finite and we do it
by learning a alphabet
on statements or in the code
so actually we learn words over
assignment communication
action and constraint this is actually a
symbolic representation
of the of our components
in addition since we need some
to learn some some
language which is regular
we choose to to learn the set of words
in
m2 which are sequences of statement
and it is regular because m2 is an
automaton
so we actually manage to find a regular
language over finite
alphabet and therefore we can
apply l star but now the learner
can raise the question but i already
know
m2 why should i learn it and the
answer here is that we might find
a much smaller assumption for the rule
so we are actually the goal of applying
l the l star is to find
an assumption for the rule
for the assume guarantee rule and we may
find
an assumption which will be much smaller
than
the m2 we are trying to learn
so here how the interaction between
the learner and the teacher goes
first of all there are the membership
queries
so the learner asks is w in the language
l the unknown language l and what the
teacher does it checks whether
this work this word is
in the sequence of
is a word in m2 but here we actually
check the sequence of statement
in m2 and if it is not then we just say
no
this word is not because we are trying
to learn the set of words of m2
on the other hand if we find that
w is in t of
m2 then which we check whether this word
composed with m1 satisfies p
and if yes if it does then we return yes
because we are looking for all the world
in
m2 that together with m1 satisfies b
if on the other hand w is in m2
but together with m1 does not satisfy p
then we actually found the real counter
example and we can stop the whole
process
because we know that m1 composed with m2
will not satisfy p here we got
an evidence for that
so now let's go to the equivalence query
the learner already come out with some
conjecture
some automaton that
he think will indeed play
plays well in the
assumed guarantee rule
so he asked the teacher whether
the language of his conjecture
equals l and now the
what the teacher does is first checking
whether this conjecture
a i together with m1 satisfies b
and if it does then it checks whether m2
is a subset of a i
and if this is actually to say that
m2 satisfies a i and if these two holds
then the premises
of the rule hold and we
conclude that m1 composed with m2
satisfies p and we can stop
we see that we didn't we didn't really
learn
m2 but we learn enough
to make the compositional rule uh
work and verify our
problem of whether m1 composed with m2
satisfies p
another possibility is that m one
composed with a i
does not satisfy p and then we get a
counter example which
is a run of a i that together with
m one does not satisfy p and then we
check whether this run is in
m2 and if it does then we get a real
counter example
and then we can stop the process because
we
actually found that m1 composed with m2
does not satisfy p
and we can go to the repair part
um on the other hand if t
is not in m2 then
we return the teacher returns no and we
need to
remove t from ai when we construct the
next
the next conjecture another possibility
is that we
get that m2 is not included in
m1 and now we need
to add um
[Music]
to 80 to a
i plus one so here is the general
framework
we have this learning we have the
we check the premises of the rule
and then we can either
we can either conclude that m1 composed
with
m2 satisfies p or that m1 composed with
m2 does not satisfy p and in the second
case we just apply repel
and we go back to learning but here we
we check whether m1 composed with the
repair
m2 satisfies p and
an important uh point is that
the process is incremental the new
application of l stars
start from the result of the previous
application of l-star because all the
answers
that were given before by the teacher
for m2 are still relevant for the
repaired m2
and this saves a lot of effort
so now let's uh consider the
repair what do we do there so we have
two kind of counter examples that we
want to get rid of
one is a
syntactic repel and the other is
semantic repel and let's start from the
semantic repair
in week in which the counter example
contains
a violating constraint so for instance
here we have a counter example
that actually reach here with an
overflow so what we do
we look for a new constraint
uh and the counter example is a specific
one for input
in which x1 is 2 to the 62
63 so we now want to find a new a
constraint that will make
the formula the set of constraints
describe
describing t infeasible
so we want to change the the program
in a way that this particular counter
example
will not be feasible anymore it will not
be
a behavior a legal behavior of the
program
for that we use abduction and
using abduction quantifier elimination
and simplification
all with the help of z3 we
get the result that the constraints we
are looking for
is to require that initially
x1 is smaller than 2 to the 63.
and now we can update our
m2 and add this
additional constraint and we can also
think of adding it to the actual program
another type of repairs are syntactic
this happens when the counter example
contain no constraints and then
abduction cannot be of help it just say
that we have a sequence of
assignment and the communications that
are
illegal illegal in the program
and then what we do is just remove
syntactically the counter example
and we have three
levels of removing counter examples
one is the exact when the counter
exactly this counter example is removed
from
m2 this is the most exact it might be
the most a slow one because we just
eliminate the counter examples one by
one
we may apply approximate
removal or aggressive removal and i will
not go into the details
so any interesting point is the
correctness and termination
of the uh of our framework
it turns out that in case m1 composed
with m2 satisfies p
then we are guaranteed to be able to
prove it
and terminate using the l-star
on the other hand when m1 composed with
m2 does not satisfy p
then the repair may add
more constraints which means that we
extend the alphabet
and in this case um we are guaranteed to
er that the pros process
will progress but we are not guaranteed
to have termination because
we may eliminate counter examples one by
one and there are might be
um infinitely many of those so
here we we are guaranteed to have a
progress in the
uh process to eliminate more and more
counter examples
but we may not terminate which is not
surprising because our setting
is of uh an infinite state system with
constraints with
variables over infinite domains
so it's not surprising that we may
not terminate so just to
to summarize we presented a learning
based assume guarantee algorithm for
infinite
state communicated communicating program
and we had to adjust l-star for handling
infinite state system the
application of l-star are incremental
and in general our experimental results
show
that we obtain quite small assumption by
the learning process and we add
a repel which is both semantic
and syntactic so to summarize the whole
at the whole lecture we had two
approaches
which are quite different both involve
verification and
repair and they are based on formal
method technology thank you
fantastic thank you warner other
questions so
um if you're in in here as an attendee
you can post questions in the q a
using the q a feature on zoom if you're
a panelist
feel free just to turn your video on and
speak up
uh hi orna uh here is rasborig this is a
very nice talk thank you can you clarify
for us i'm sure you mentioned it how do
you ensure that
you don't remove behaviors that are
desired
meaning you prepare to satisfy safety
but is it possible that you remove
behaviors that we
desire to have actually yes
so the program the
specification does not require certain
behavior to exist
we don't have an existential behavior
so it's just a set of behaviors that
must that are legal and the
the system uh need to conform with those
um and we may remove uh too much
actually in certain cases where we use
the aggressive
syntactic repair then we ended up
in an empty
component which theoretically is correct
but of course
this is not what we aim it
so we don't have a meaning
to avoid removing
removing behavior that are desired
because
the specification doesn't give
indication an indication of
which behaviors are desired
must stay there so maybe we need
to consider a specification
that insist on some behavior to be there
and then
they cannot be removed so at least a set
of test cases perhaps right
okay this is another uh possibility that
we consider to
combine test-based approach with
the formal approach just to get a lower
bound on the behaviors that you preserve
right thank you one one question about
the first part of the
talk is there a connection between
unsatisfiable
core in set formulas and the
must locations that you identify
and not necessarily
when we compute it as you saw we are not
using
answered core this is what you were
asking
about i understand that it's not what
you did but i wonder whether there is a
connection in the sense that you could
perhaps phrase it as such
and then obtain those statements as
unsatisfiable core of a
constraint system so other
works there is at least one work i don't
remember
now the name that use
answered core and i think that the
problem with
most of other approach is that in
in a sense they will ignore the
conditions in the program they
and sometimes the condition is the
reason for the bag
if you change the the condition itself
then you will correct the bag and
many of the other approach for fault
localization just
ignore the conditions especially
like in our case where the
execution didn't get into the if
statement
at all because the condition was false
so so in that case
uh most of the works that we
examined uh do not produce a must for
localization but
in may thank you thank you very much
great so owner i have a question about
the second part of the talk the learning
based assume
uh guarantee algorithm so it's it's
using automatic learning
approaches to to find fine counter
examples
um in in these sort of settings where
you have a lot of
relationships i'm sorry it uses
the learning to find an assumption for
the assumed guarantee rule
right right to to you know with the aim
of of identifying these
counter examples right i mean this is
this is kind of one output from this
process
um okay yeah actually
okay i'm sorry maybe i maybe i've
misunderstood
so actually the learning uh the
traditional use of learning in assumed
guarantee
tries to find all the
behaviors that together with
m1 will satisfy the program this is the
target
right right so it's it's identifying
that
that language in in many of these
um settings uh where you're solving a
lot of related
learning problems the um
i guess here you can get by without
without um
uh actually solving uh identifying this
this language right and and so the order
in which you
approach the truth is very important
you know in the sense of how rapidly
that process proceeds
um in in lots of
different different formal uh settings
for the learning problems but related
learning problems there are there are
these uh transfer learning approaches
that aim to use
you know a collection of related
learning tasks and exploit commonalities
between them to
to speed up the process um you know it
seems like
um that could be something very useful
to to shape the inductive bias of this
process
in in in the setting that you you have
here is there any prospect of using
those approaches here or is this
something new
uh i don't know uh which work can you
tell me again which one i mean there's a
broad area
i i haven't seen it in you know when
you're working with with membership and
equivalence queries for for these kinds
of problems but for
um learning from examples there's this
broad area of transfer learning where
you
you have a number of related problems
maybe maybe there are
somehow related computer vision problems
um you know and you can hope to exploit
commonalities across those problems
to uh for for any new task to learn that
faster
yeah it's an interesting idea we can try
and
see if it's useful in this uh
in this context yes
all right if there are no other
questions
um please join me in in thanking orna um
for a wonderful talk that was
uh very interesting just like to think
about thanks owner
thank you